I think I may have taken a wrong turn on
the way to the office this morning okay
so I'm actually back in Oxford and I'm
back for a live stream so and this here
is the studio underneath the IT services
the University of Oxford this has been a
completely flying business so about 15
minutes after Graham wife I'm talking to
a bunch of expert different disciplines
about the topic of immortality and it
would you like to live forever anyway I
need to get on stage
[Music]
well that went rather well you can also
see here that's the physics fun well
part of it as the astrophysics building
that's where I spent a lot of a tutorial
time yeah that livestream I'm pretty
well you can actually watch out and
clearly link down there it's for this
website what Explorer which is the
University of Oxford's new website
promoting big ideas and getting kids in
schools to think about this big
questions so this one was about what you
want in the forever but there are gonna
be other ones in the future so it was it
was genuinely really really interesting
to be partner so thank you Alex Alex but
for a revive me to do so I'm currently
walking down this street which I walk
down every day basically have my
undergraduate because I'm going for all
the physics department back to some
Peters cuz I'm doing some more film this
was my home for you tomorrow so I'm back
in some Peters to film this man knows II
don't even is the title schools there's
not so so you do it's access work
basically trying to encourage people to
apply to Oxford and people like asks you
in state schools yeah particularly so
we're doing as a rather swanky if I may
say so myself set up weekly coordinators
so Dunn's a really interesting guy he's
like mean that he came to Oxford from a
state school nobody didn't have been to
uni before from his family I think and
like me he's been doing access for
absolutely years it was his one thing I
asked him if there was one thing he
wished that people just knew about
Oxford access meetings I go to very
important people from government to
University importance as well who are
always talking about how we change the
representation in this university and
the types of students that apply here
how we track them and also the processes
by which they're admitted it's a
conversation that basically goes on
every single day now you may not think
that they're going on sometimes they
perhaps they haven't quite reached you
yet or they might be focusing on maybe
teachers this week or people in care
another week but the the range of
different sorts of representation that
we want to
rather than how to change it as a
conversation is continually going on
this is some Peters by the way this was
my home this is a Linton quarter that I
made at the moment so that's Linden
house that's the library up top I'll
have to do some proper videos about this
one day that was when my tutor was in
the incredibly ugly Latin er building
that's the chapel which is huge relative
to the size of the college it's like
another parish church basically but it's
an amazing acoustic and that way is a
building site this is Marbury quad and
that staircase for which is where some
of my friends lived and down there is
the best bar in all of Oxford
it's closed some things I do absolutely
love it here and it has changed quite a
bit well you can see this building work
at the moment it has changed quite a bit
since I've been here but it's always
gonna feel like home and every time I
come back it feels like how and the
porters are the same the master still
recognizes me and asks how I'm doing I
know that I can always come back which
is on those benefits to an Oxford
education that they just kind of tell
you about you get a new home in a new
family now it's time to get all of this
gear on a train in their own by myself
should be good well that was horrible
[Music]
so I'm back in Exeter and I'm going to
talk about the work tomorrow in the blog
because today well all week as a matter
of fact this is happening
it's freshers week so this is the week
when you know society's trying accrue
new freshers into their societies so I
think they get divided up by kind of
classification so today is all the
sports people which I mean for goodness
sake in this one shot you've got the
water polo club
there's the like skiing people exa I'm
actually quite sure it stands for
you've got the cross you've got rugby
league you've got rowing then just over
here that's what I think Taekwondo doing
a demonstration for crushes to varying
degrees of success the actual Boat Club
not rowing but they actually vote most
important you've got the ice cream truck
we've got these dudes skateboarding
which I think it's a society and not
just people messing around I'm not sure
if you've got core for these kids these
students you have coming up to
university meetings supposed to uni for
the first time
they were in primary school when I was
finishing my a-levels
this is my ninth freshest book
[Music]
but this wasn't originally part of the
plan for this blog this week but I just
got ambushed by these two so write the
story here is it banker you stalked me
and reported my physician - I just came
here these two people just turn your in
the blog say hi parent service my mom
dad have made it finally
okay nice so I just went for a quick
cheeky run her butt back now about to do
some editing for next couple of hours I
thought because I showed you my ninth
freshers week today it might be fun to
go back and talk about my my freshers
week my first one in submeters which you
saw yesterday
so obviously freshers was a huge deal
for me as it is for everybody and it was
the first time that I've lived away from
home for any really significant amount
of time and I remember we drove up there
with a car that was really way too full
of stuff it was quite fun because when
you're when you drive to uni like that
you see other cars they're heading in
the same direction as you and they're
also stuffed with things and you're like
we know you're going I remember I got
I'm really orange can I do something
about this so I remember being dropped
off and the first place I went to is at
the bar that was some foreshadowing in
retrospect and about these two girls
bring he and Tara I can't remember I
told the story before but there were the
first two people I met in Peters and
they were unbelievably friendly and nice
and literally from the work go I felt at
home and that was basically that the
tone for the rest of the week I fit in
really well and I didn't enjoy my first
year at Oxford a huge amount because I
didn't adapt the work very well I worked
myself too hard because I thought it was
just like school if I keep pushing
I'd eventually just get it and I didn't
realize that if I did it at the rate the
Oxford required of me I was gonna burn
out which I did also I was in a
relationship at the time which meant I
was leaving Oxford a lot so I didn't
really develop a social group because
when I wasn't Oxford I was just working
all the time but my fresh this week was
the FIR we did two weeks away from each
other for both but fresh as we
deliberately and I'm so glad we did
because I actually got to know people
and know people that I still talk to now
on Facebook and Twitter so at the time
some Peters had a croquet lawn because
of course it's not for college and they
put up the marquee which is in these
pictures which was amazing like to have
a tent basically with a chandelier on a
croquet little nose like yeah I think
I've arrived I think this is Oxford now
and the second news arranged a bunch of
drinking games and non drinking games
I'd like to point out it wasn't just
drinking although for some reason the
drinking ones like shot wheel bar races
just stuck in my mind interesting enough
I also took pictures of the bar because
well for one thing it is the best bar in
Oxford no question it's also my favorite
bar in the world because just so many
memories there and the beer was one
pound sixty a point which is for this
view not in the UK really cheap also in
there they did a jazz jam and I played
sax in there and I didn't do this at any
other point and when I was in Oxford
no I think I did it one other time maybe
the basically just turn it with this
turn you play and we didn't have I
didn't have a clue what I was doing I
never done anything like it before
I just turned up I was like yeah I can
play jazz on the saxophone I played a
little bit before whenever anything life
it was really fun I love doing it I look
like a [ __ ] there are other aspects to
talk about like um my room which was a
new block those of you out some Peters
and Hall and all that kind of stuff but
I think anybody who knew me in freshers
week and watch these videos actually if
you please comment it would be
unforgivable for me not to talk about my
stormtrooper costume this thing as far
as I could tell was basically what I was
known for in some pieces because the
first Bop which is basically a fancy
dress party that they're always themed
and the first pot for some Peters was
something beginning with s or P or C
because some Peters college and I went
for the S I went through a stormtrooper
not like should stuff all know stern up
Tai Lung I mean like a Star Wars
stormtrooper and I made the thing I am
it was a big undertaking because I built
the whole thing that cardboard and
papier-mache and won World War two like
plastic helmet which I bought and it was
unbelievably uncomfortable because the
legs were just like cylinders of
cardboard so they just rode right up
into my groin when I walked and I
basically managed to wear about an hour
before I had to take it off but it was
amazing and I think I think I made
covered in prat
of an impression for the last few years
my proudest part that by the way with
the pauldrons the shoulder bits because
they were two halves of a papier-mache
cover balloon like pot and then yes it's
a like put back my mesh over and let it
harden pop the balloon painted it or
white and then they were my like
shoulder pieces that was fun
I actually busted it out again for my
final bob I wore it for the first one
after the last one I didn't go to many
bops to be fair for the last one I
upgraded it like I made the legs more
ergonomic I put I pieces in I had a
little pair of sunglasses and put them
in the in the eye holes I was really
proud of that thing that I had I wore it
one other time and then I had to throw
it away because it's just in a bag but
that was that was my magnum opus for
those of you who might be watching this
with the title it has and going to
freshers week soon I would recommend get
involved don't be shy I mean obviously
it's scary I remember being scared I'm
quite an introverted person but I think
it's important to just say I don't often
do this on channel one I'm just going to
censor it safe kit because why not you
know you you and it's like starting
complete new life and particularly in
non college universities you've got to
get yourself involved in societies that
are about things you're interested in
because that's how you make friends with
you know with people who are interested
in the same things as you it'll
experience a little bit different you
know you've kind of apt you don't have
to but you know you have already made
friendship you know college but then get
involved in the college stuff get to
know people get chatting often people
develop ridiculous personas when they go
to to freshers week to kind of just spin
around it can be totally different and
wild don't do that be yourself but just
try and be the outgoing version of
yourself try things signup to loads of
societies go to one event of each if you
find one that you really like go for it
there's nothing wrong with going to the
society and then just removing yourself
in the mailing list also drinking is a
big part of uni culture in the UK if
we're being honest but you don't have to
drink I don't think anybody who you
shouldn't be worried about anybody
forces you to dream because you can
always say no and if you're
uncomfortable say no the people that are
gonna be forcing you are lowlifes so
don't worry about that but equally if
you want to drink do drink just know
your limits fractures is the classic
time when people don't do this but like
just be safe okay
be aware of where you're at in terms of
drink and don't
quickly alternate between hard drinks
and soft drinks believe me that is a pro
tip and also don't do ten shots of
sambuca in a row because it will end
badly
right now with that and the light
suddenly making an appearance I'm gonna
get some Webb done but I'll see you
tomorrow so they're all manner of
wonderful things about exodus campus and
there are all kinds of great things
about staying late for someone like me
one of which is wildlife on campus
because behind me over there is a happy
little badger Daisy do you want from UK
maybe you don't know what this is it's
quite a large nocturnal animal there's a
lot of controversy about culling them
which is completely unscientific they're
basically blind so as long as I'm quiet
and I stayed downwind it's not gonna
freak out
there he goes you could seriously do a
whole wildlife show about the wildlife
on campus because we sleep badgers foxes
rabbits squirrels loads of different
person I don't know very much about
birds um but basically because the
campus is so nice when all the students
are you know it's been quiet like at
night
well these animals come out that's great
okay Wow a strange day
hang on haven't put any gunk in my hair
one sec so all good things must come to
an end and I am moving out at the house
this is all happening very quickly I'm
basically going to stay with a friend
Michael on his in his spare room for the
rest of the time that I'm doing the
thesis because hopefully it's well it's
gonna be less than two months so it's a
temporary arrangement and I'm I'm
basically getting all my stuff together
today so I haven't go into work I've
actually been packing all morning and
I've also been editing
I've been hopefully these have come out
a long time ago I've been putting
together all the Oxbridge videos that
I've I've made so little two-minute
one's about GCSEs and personal statement
and stuff like that so quite an intense
morning actually now the reason that
it's really important that I move out
now is because this is what our living
room looks like this is Ed's forcing
himself to live well wait forcing him to
live more specifically I'm forcing him
to live out of bags and sleeping on the
sofa and frankly this is untenable we
just can't keep living like this so I'm
getting out of here so so far today I
have edited six videos I did my beard
one and I did the Oxbridge ones I just
had lunch and I just watched a bunch of
YouTube for inspiration and now it's
like yeah let's make this seven baby if
it's all right with you I'm gonna do
greenify you know I'm just going to keep
you here whilst I start getting this
edit set up I like watching YouTube for
inspiration in the same way that I know
that's as wide as it goes professional
youtuber I presume in the same way that
writers like to read novels you know
it's it's
inspiration for your style and
inevitably makes you feel both better
and worse about yourself because mm-hmm
you always sort of watch other people's
videos and think oh god they're so good
that's just but the problem of course is
that I'm watching I mean in that one
sitting I must have watched like 10
videos and like whilst eating lunch and
I don't think I watch more than one
video per channel and so like you know
each one of those people might put up
one video a month I mean they don't they
put up more frequently than that but it
might be one like feature what I think
of his feature videos per month you know
and so I'm just getting through them in
like over the course of an hour or so
and it's just like it's it's overload
from from like a stylistic and video
making perspective because I'm on the
receiving end but if I was to watch each
one of the being made I would see the
craft that goes into them and in some
cases you know the weeks of effort for
example sovietwomble who's a current
favorite channel of mine had a weird
dream that was in a sovietwomble video
the other day
and for other people's videos like Vox
you know multiple people working on it
and also people who are doing it
full-time rather than trying to do it
alongside a PhD although admittedly
today and in fact in this vlog in
generally you haven't seen very much
work and that's because I don't wanna
sound like a stuck record because at the
moment my life is basically just working
today is an exception that I've taken a
day off to pack which you might be able
to see just a frame there to pack to get
everything ready and to get a bunch of
videos out because with these videos if
I can get them all done today this is
like three weeks worth of content I'd
have to edit for a while so I can really
focus in on the PhD so it's like
investing time that's I'm thinking of it
I also just happen to like editing don't
know time-lapse let's do a time-lapse
have another time-lapse this vlog yeah
have you know that's definitely a lie I
always do time lapses how many more
times can I say time that's before I run
at breath time lapse time lapse time
lapse time those down
[Music]
all right time to move house okay so it
is much much later I've had a few beers
and I moved in so this is my new home
this is basically my friend Michaels
can't focus on me please this is my
friend Michael's study and he's letting
me staying for the next couple of weeks
while I finish my PhD this is gonna be
the room where I possibly write the last
sentences of my PhD
[Music]
the paddle in those days were really
really struggled to vlog
to be honest I've really struggled to do
anything today I feel like I just didn't
really wake up this morning even its
cameras cockeyed hang on
[Music]
like I've been putting off talking to
camera
partly because I've been in the office a
lot and I haven't been in the office
have been in the forum and there's a lot
of people in the forum because it's
freshers week and a lot of people in the
office at the moment so I'm not having
much fun opportunity to flop but also
it's like what do I talk about at the
end of the day this vlog is about me
doing my PhD and that is a very boring
repetitious process especially at the
moment I have spent all day well I mean
I've been changing the write-up in my
thesis because I did something in one
coordinate system and I I was basically
cheating no not cheating but I was doing
a simplified version instead of doing
something in latitude/longitude I was
doing it in X&Y
so basically pretending the earth was
flat and I could completely do that
because you make this approximate the
earth is so big that locally like here
the earth is flat right hashtag flat
earthers so in terms of the derivation
that was doing it doesn't change
anything I just needed to rewrite this
whole section which didn't take very
long and since then there's a factor of
10 or it might be a factor of G which is
9.81 ish that's gone rogue in one of my
equations I can't find it anywhere
and basically the that's something going
a little bit awry so my day is consisted
of trolling through code I'm trying to
find a factor of 10 or G and there's so
many places it could be
it's not even computer science it's just
checking through if it's about 4
programs and each of them are like a few
hundred lines long and it's like that
might not sound very much but it's just
it doesn't it doesn't help yes it's not
very much and if I was laser laser
focused I could probably do it in a day
but I'm at this point with the PhD I am
just exhausted if I'm being completely
honest in this blog which is you know
one of the things that's important to be
I am just exhausted even though it took
yesterday off effectively with the move
and I gave myself a nice lion just
walked out my new room this morning
I'm just naked I really am I've also had
a very massage heavy day I can't stop
playing with it I realized that I could
curl it up like this supposed to put wax
in it I could like dull mmm so yeah this
has been distracting me because yeah I
want to get this thing off my face so
badly I've got to just finish where are
you hiding you're in it somewhere or
possibly one of these other files
[Music]
so I've had a realization is not a
factor of G or a factor a ten expected
to pie and I know that because I able to
really scientifically this makes life a
lot nicer because that means it's a
geometric factor and not like a physical
factor if it was G then that would mean
there was something wrong with my
equations when there clearly wasn't
whereas if it's two pi that means it's
basically how I'm integrating something
so that makes life a lot better I just
ran the wrong program like an idiot I'm
running the right program now this run
feels important no just turned to camera
to in order to talk about it there is no
camera to I just moved camera one see I
can move it anywhere do you see that
would have been visible in frame in that
last camera it's amazing where you can
do a bond camera if you're creative or
bored
[Music]
so now I've set before in this blog
forms been busy this week well
yeah this is precious man
[Music]
that was taken by my dad don't see how
much free stuff you got how many use it
even at the TV so I don't know how out
of this I've got the microphone really
close but basically we're helping out on
the chapel stove and Dan and Becky have
just gone together oh they're just
arrived
[Music]
you go they win stand at all
so the freshers fayre is the main
opportunity that student societies get
to recruit new members basically it's
the formal point at which you sign up to
whatever it is you want to do whether
that's music or sport whatever plan much
as I would love to be sat on a desk talk
to people about Chapel Choir and meeting
fans of the vlog because I have met
quite a few of you this week I'm instead
back in the office it's got to be done
though I want to finish I've got to work
okay so I found where the problem was
with my code it's currently fixing
itself I think at the moment it wasn't
the factor to PI it was a factor of
about two pi and it stems from a really
basic stupid mistake as it always does
with me let me explain this might be
very basic for some of you watching this
but it's mistake I made so you know
probably worth repeating so let's say
that I was interested in working out the
area of a rectangle here's one I made
out of it and that angle was got area a
and it's got a height H and width W
width W and anybody who's done that
beyond the age of like 12 can tell you
that a equals H times W easy that wasn't
mistake I made that's the end result you
want right but what you could do is
break up for example if it just being W
you could have lots of tiny little w's
actually if you think about this let's
think if this is x and y you know like a
like a graph then this is DX that little
tiny bit of width W then is just the sum
of all of those little DX is put
together or end-on-end the length of all
the ladder together and you can write
that a mass for stuff that is really
really small where it's DX you can write
that as the integral that's what that
sign means of DX literally you just add
them all up that's all that means
and similarly H is equal to the integral
of dy where dy is the tiny little
element
at the vertical and technically they're
not really small they're infinitesimally
so they can't be any smaller they'd
cease to exist so a calls H times W then
you could just write it that it's equal
to this times this and you can do that
in integrals by doing a double integral
so you're integrating once DX and once
with you I close through exactly the
same now this is really easy for a
rectangle because the DX is and the D
wives don't change so you might question
why you'd want to do this but let's say
that you want to work out the surface
area of a sphere this is a very bad
drawing atmosphere sorry I'm not very
good at art now instead of having DX and
dy the two coordinates that you used to
specify any point on a sphere are
latitude and longitude right and
typically I would write that in my
thesis as lambda and theta to Greek
letters so the size of your little area
let your DX times dy but your than
adding over the whole thing that now
becomes D lambda times D theta a little
bit of longer to times a little bit of
latitude that corresponds like a square
on the ground but it's not quite that
simple I apologize for the drawing I'm
about to do this is gonna be terrible
let's say that we're looking down a near
the North Pole of this sphere if it was
to say this was the earth were looking
down on the North Pole Oh God
so the North Pole is say here and let's
draw some lines of latitude around it I
now also going to add some lines of
longitude now they're not gonna look it
but that's just assume right the each of
these they're equally distributed so say
I don't know
this is longer to you 10 this is
longitude 20 longer to 30 whatever and
the same for these latitudes let's say
the this is say an 80 70 60 50 the point
is there's a difference of 10 between
each solid line and a difference of 10
between each dotted line that that means
that this area
if we were to choose our DC certainty
lambda D lassitude along with you to be
10 each that would be one chunk that you
add up but remember that the difference
in these lines are the same but this
area here it's so much bigger than this
area here it's bound like 10 difference
on each side that this fit is smaller
because it's closer to the power it's
close to where you're defining your
latitudes as going up to 90 degrees and
herein lies Simon mistake of the vlog
normally in spherical coordinates which
means that you specify a last year
longitude and radius but because you can
assume the Earth's radius is about
constant let's actually say the earth
rate is a day you'd specify that the
size of one of these areas is given by a
D theta
your infant a thermal increase of
latitude times a sine theta D lambda so
this if you like corresponds to your dy
like it's d-mail up it's this bit I
don't know rub it off it's that it's
that section whereas the the a sine
theta dy is this but it's the X and if
you notice that R is bigger than that
it's bigger than that how can bigger
than our search that when you're at the
pole your DX is well it's a times sine
of 90 which is what oh that's where I
went wrong because I was taught this in
an abstract kind of context right it
wasn't in a geographical context it was
generally in spherical coordinates and
latitude in spherical coordinates the
theta doesn't normally run from 90 to
minus 90 life it does on the earth it
runs from zero to 180 because it just
sort of feels a bit nicer
however because last year on the earth
varies from 90 to minus 90 you have to
change your sign to a cos because you
want it to be zero at the pole so cos of
90 is zero and cos of minus 90 is zero
because at zero is
such that your DX near DUI are the same
which is what you want on the equator in
calculating an area I had sine measured
about cars and that produce a difference
because it was one minus where the
figure was one minus cost sixty five as
opposed to one minus sine sixty five
that meant there was a difference
instead of being naught point one it was
not point six so about a difference of
two pi which is about six and oh it's a
stupid mistake but code is currently
running just gonna fix that I'm pretty
pleased with that drawing kind of sat on
it up yeah Carol is currently running
it's basically updating all of the cases
where I've used an area on the plat it's
a yeah it's a small mistake but it makes
a massive difference so fingers crossed
that's basically the last bit of
fiddling I have to do my theory chapter
so I forgot how long this code takes to
run yeah this is gonna take for the rest
of the day I think I've been doing
emails and stuff and then like I just I
knew is gonna tell you one time put it
in the terminal watch these numbers
counts up and I was like oh
after a couple of hours this isn't gonna
get done today so I think I'm gonna have
to leave this running overnight which
means I get to go home early seventy
five o'clock on a Saturday and I get to
go home I've got more work to do got it
you know okay I made a friend walking
hey you're very friendly and we've got
bit mud on me hey hey hey you can scent
mark or you want back still mine how
many students have you done this to
today sort that out
t but oh I don't know if I've ever been
as consistently tired as I am the hell I
it's it's eight o'clock and I am dying
it is tough at the moment
like I think you could do a pros and
cons list of my life and obviously in
the cons you've got I'm living in
somebody's front room which is typical
of my old room was I'm sleeping on a
sofa bed I am doing a PhD I'm into my
ninth year of higher education because
of a disagreement between my supervisors
despite the fact that I've been working
as hard as I can
I am constantly tired basically with the
joy I know from my degree as laughs
texture so I'm kind of on my own and I'm
working everyday until like 9 or 10 but
the plus side I'm alive I've got a great
relationship I'm working on a PhD which
is an immense privilege even though not
being paid to do it anymore
still an amazing privilege to do it and
I know that afterwards I get a crack at
doing the thing I'm really passionate
about I'm doing video production and
trying to trying to do science as a
career I don't have a phone that works I
think it's important to keep everything
perspective at the end of the day I'm
still one of the luckiest people on the
planet there's no two ways of looking at
it I am I'm just tired
go stop whining start living I slept for
nine and a half hours last night and I
am still knackered so today is kind of
an odd one normally I'd be going up to
campus to work in my office but because
they keep my key card isn't let me in
the building anymore I need to get a new
card and it's Sunday and I should
probably taking things a little bit easy
because our tie down I'm gonna go and
work in a coffee shop I was just working
for a couple of hours unfortunately that
wasn't terribly productive basically I
was like aha I found something I found a
mistake I went through a change that or
then realized that I was actually right
the first time because I thought about
this subtlety more carefully before so I
had to change it all back so kind of
going in circles so not much progress
come back home and that was me I was
about to record some audio for some
Oxbridge videos but I don't if you can
hear
I'm so close to the cathedral in town
now buddy I just got to wait for this to
stop I have no idea how long this is
gonna be could be hours so in the
meantime I'm doing a bit of editing and
also running some stuff boom that's
finished burning some stuff on my
computer they're still going those are
in the past two hours my computer
started doing this like if I move the
mouse yeah I'm not quite sure what's
gone wrong
well that's so I'm not sure what's gone
wrong here this should be close to one
well you shouldn't do that at the bottom
please so a bunch of videos I've edited
are now uploading and I've given up on
worrying about the PhD for today that's
that's Monday Monday Simon's problem I'm
now gonna go and sneak in my first run
for the new house what about hurt that
as much as I did before so I may have
messed up my timings slightly
[Music]
Oh
so that was a first for me I just went
to my first service where I wasn't in
the chapel choir just watched instead
watch this I'm going to turn it over
them so that's the last service I'll be
doing without new scholars they're
coming in this year so it's kind of to
impress the people who are coming to
audition which I think it did now I'm
staying on campus because I've been
looking forward to a week the return of
all my favorite bars of the Uni it's the
campus in LA now this definitely isn't
something I need to do in fact kind of
seeing a film
I've already seen and it's not even
practical for me to go because I need to
eat and this makes life very difficult
but I'm looking forward to this plus as
I thought it would be it looks like it's
gonna be absolutely packed
when seeing a film in the campus cinema
with loads people is just kind of unique
like this is fun
[Music]
should I forgot have fun that film was
the second time I've seen guardians -
the first time I actually did a review
at dam which if you haven't seen no
include down below oh yeah I'd like to
develop it on the second viewing like I
said like I said before there's
something different about watching it in
a room full of students it's just more
fun and like everybody laughs of the
jokes and there's yeah it was exactly
what I needed right now
it's 11:30 on Sunday which means that
this vlog has to end because extended
week but it's not the end of my week
because whilst it is actually it's gone
past midnight I have to stop and pick up
a subway I haven't eaten yet what's that
is gone midnight I still have what to do
I have a vlog to finish I said I would
finish it and I'm going to finish it so
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be editing for a
little while yet thank you for watching
this vlog and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]